welcome back to the David Pakman show
Donald Trump is a historic loser
and this is not hyperbole this is not
just me trying to make something out of
nothing
fivethirtyeight.com has shown a there's
a graph that will pull up on your screen
and you could see that Donald Trump's
approval ratings have hit a new low of
37 point 7 percent this is the lowest
point in any president since we've been
recording these approval polls this is
the lowest point for a president that's
ten months in to the presidency
there's also a image from Real Clear
Politics that kind of confirms this
their numbers are a little bit higher
shows that Donald Trump's approval
rating is at thirty eight point seven
percent with a disapproval rating of
fifty five point nine percent again
historically low numbers I think this is
important to point out for a few reasons
that it's worth us discussing number one
this idea that Donald Trump won the
United States presence the President of
the United States on some type of
fantastic strategy I think it's
fallacious right because a couple of
things have happened since he's become
president he has not gotten any
legislative victories his agenda has
been a complete flop with the exception
of what he can accomplish through using
the pin of the executive order that's
all he's able to do he's not able to
build coalitions he's not able to rally
anyone around his plan he's definitely
not going to get bipartisan support
support on anything the I think the most
he has accomplished with bipartisan
support was the confirmation of Neil
gorsek and that was with one or two
Democrats namely Joe Manchin of West
Virginia so Donald Trump is historically
unpopular but he is yet again still
people are still championing him as
though he is some type of historic hero
or a revolutionary figure I'm reminded
again of Steve Ben and his former
strategist who was fired by the way who
spoke at the values the so called Values
Voter Summit over the weekend and Steve
Bannon began to describe the possibility
of Donald Trump winning electoral ebuy
for 400 electoral votes in 2020 see this
is this is when you have drunk your own
kool-aid and I think they believe that
because don't Trump won that it was his
strategy that won when in actuality I
would argue that it's much more the win
for Donald Trump was much more about the
Democrats losing it wasn't so much the
Donald Trump had a strategy that was a
winning strategy it was that the
Democrats made a lot of mistakes they
they they made a lot of errors that
simply handed this to Donald Trump and
this is why it's important for us to
discuss there are a lot of people in
commentary positions journalists there's
a lot of people making the arguments
that Donald Trump's strategy of anti
political correctness was the strategy
that people need to adjust for in the
sense that whenever Donald Trump says
something that isn't that it's
politically incorrect
we should not correct them because if we
correct them then we're gonna come off
as PC and everybody hates PC culture
that's not really the case that's not
why Donald Trump won Donald Trump's
historically low approval ratings should
demonstrate that to you that people do
not want to be associated with them save
that 38% that would never abandon him no
matter what he does there is a core
group of Republican voters who no matter
what Donald Trump does like he said he
if he goes to 5th Avenue and shoot
somebody they will still support him so
there's always gonna be that group of
people who no matter what he does
they're going to love him they're gonna
support him and those are the people who
truly genuinely believe that the anti PC
culture is what got them to the White
House therefore that's what they should
continue and and so this has become
something that people are drawing
lessons out of that they should not
learn there are no lessons in Donald
Trump being anti PC as a as a symbol of
virtue right there is no virtue in
Donald Trump's anti political
correctness it is backed by and
spectacularly
you even have a particularly publican
who has all the records thought about
impeaching Donald Trump this is how
unpopular he is by the sheer fact of
what his incompetence mind you but then
to his office niskanen err his way with
words or the lack thereof Donald Trump
is a historic loser and I think it means
a lot more than what people are really
looking into it means that if we are
going to make any adjustments in the on
the Democratic side on the progressive
side or the left whatever you want to
call it there's a broad spectrum if
there are lessons to be learned and
we're going to adjust our strategy
it should not be adjusting our strategy
to compensate for Donald Trump's new
revolutionary way of doing politics
which is anti PC that's the last thing
that we should do anti political
correctness has a life shelf a shelf
life and Donald Trump has run it out and
here we see based on the approval
ratings exactly how far anti political
correctness can get you anti political
correctness can get you to the White
House if Democrats continue to make the
same mistakes that they made in 2016
which is to not have a concise message
to not really be running on anything as
much as they are running against that's
the lesson to learn in this in this
entire process the lesson that Democrats
and people who want to oppose Donald
Trump I don't care what party it is if
you're in the opposition of Donald Trump
it's not that you should become anti PC
so that you could compete with Donald
Trump's new revolution Larry brave new
world that's not the lesson if anything
it should be have something that you
stand for it don't only oppose Donald
Trump's office nests but what do you
fight for what are you fighting for
there's absolutely no reason in the
world why every single Democrat should
not be fighting for Medicare for all
where every single Democrat should be
fighting for depending on their state an
increase in the minimum wage there's no
reason in the world that we should not
have a concise that anybody who's
opposing Donald Trump Democrat Green
Party whoever you are should not have a
concise message of what you represent
and what you stand for the bonus the
bonus for your campaign is the fact that
Donald Trump is a historic loser that
every time he opens his mouth he loses
more
support and so Donald Trump is going to
do more to sabotage himself than what
any of anyone else can do all we have to
do is have a clear-eyed focus on what we
represent and what we stand for beyond I
don't know if I should approach this
this particular aspect of it
but it should be above and beyond
identity politics see the the lesson
that's trying to be imbued in unto
Democrats is that we should abandon
identity politics and that's exactly
what Steve Bennett would love that is
his that is his lucid dream that's what
he would want more than anything else is
for no one to ever address identity
politics ever again and that is not what
that's not the lesson from this election
the lesson from this election is you
have to have more than identity politics
if you address identity great fine we
need to we should because there are a
lot of people who are being targeted
right now because of their identity the
LGBTQ community is targeted because of
their identity people of the Islamic
faith they are targets specifically
because of their identity anybody who
wants to deny that at this point there's
you're part of that 38% who support
Donald Trump bottom line but the lesson
from the election is that we have to
have more it has to be both and so we
have to go above and beyond simply
talking about identity we have to go to
other solutions on top of it but what
the let the lesson that Steve Bannon
wants you to learn the lesson that
Donald Trump wants you to learn is to
completely and utterly reject any
politics based on someone's identity and
that's not the lesson to learn
case in point look at where Donald Trump
is in his holding numbers right now
Donald Trump may not make it to 2020 as
the President of the United States not
because of Russia not because of any of
anything well I mean Russia may end up
coming to grab bite him in the behind
but ultimately he may not make it
because he is so historically unpopular
that Republicans are going to go down
with him if they don't turn on him and
that's because of his character that's
because of his demeanor that's because
of his approach to identity politics and
this is approach to marginalized groups
everything about Donald Trump is is an
to people of decent moral thinking and
common sense except for that 38% at 38%
no matter what he does they are going to
always support him and so we can't worry
about that group though that group is an
extremist group that exists in America
they'll never go anywhere so why would
we try to cater to them why would we try
to placate them we should not try to
service the entire we should not try to
appeal to the broader American
electorate by appealing to the
extremists who still support Donald
Trump so make sure that when we try to
learn the lessons from this election
it's not taking lessons from people who
stumbled into the White House because of
the mistakes of the Democratic Party
thinking that they have some magical and
mystical brand new type of politics the
anti PC politics is the way no that's
not the lesson the lesson is if we have
to you that we have to address identity
politics which we should we need to do
that and then some everything has to be
on the table we have to have a solid
plan that goes beyond just discussing
identity but we should not abandon
identity because that's exactly what
Steve Bannon wants you to do thinking
that you're learning a lesson from the
election that's not really being there
for us that's not there for us to learn
all right we'll be back after this